so I have another crop of 10 philosophy
related questions and I'm going to
answer each of these and try to do it
under two minutes in another 10 shorts
sequence so a lot of these are dealing
with topics and political theory or an
epistemology and then there's a few that
are that are focused on specific
philosophical thinkers or movements
so end authority and I perhaps that name
is a little bit revealing says what are
your opinions on property rights
specifically John Locke's ideas of
property rights and as the question goes
on it's clear that that user does not
think very highly of them so two
questions really rolled into one there
and I'm going to focus more on unlock do
I think that property is in all cases a
sort of absolute right once a person has
property that they have an absolute
right to it that you know only they can
can alienate I don't think so as a
matter of fact lock even seems to
suggest that if somebody is being
totally irrational in their use of
property that they don't have a complete
right to it as well do I think that that
locks labor theory of property that is
by mixing one's labor which one owns
according to lock in with raw materials
or with materials that one is getting
from somebody else that it makes it
one's own that gives a person to write
to have that as their their own property
and not to be interfered with by other
people I actually find that kind of
reasonable it's not it's not something
that can be elevated into an absolute
principle in the single basis for
understanding of property but it does
make sense to say that the people who
you know if we had for example you know
uncultivated land and the people who
actually invest the time and labor into
it ought to have a right to that and
that that right wat to be respected by
others then that makes some sense you
know there it gets into a lot of tricky
questions like if I start chasing the
deer but I'm not the person who kills it
do I get to have it and once we start
talking about a market economy that's
based around specialization of Labor and
exchange it gets it gets rather tricky
and and his theory starts to break down
but I think that it has some merits to
it
this is the first of three questions
asked to me by Melanie grace zip again
who is in a class where her professor is
introduced her to a number of different
theories and theorists and wants her to
answer these very questions and she
wants to think about how would they be
answered you know according to Plato or
Aquinas or stuff like that I'm not going
to answer them that way because i'm not
going to do her homework for her but i
will answer these questions which are
very interesting like should people
overthrow the government and about that
i'll say two main things one is that
many philosophers would say that there
are conditions under which it would be
right for for people to overthrow the
government that they're being ruled by
and there's a lot of different factors
that would go into it the arbitrariness
of the government whether the government
is actually effectively you know
promoting the goods of the people that
are being governed you know what the
what the possible replacement would be
all these are things that would have to
be taken into consideration but I'm very
attracted to thinkers who will think of
this in terms of the common good is the
government actually governing for the
good of those who are under its its
charge or is it doing it for the benefit
of say its constituents against you know
the other party's constituents by this
you know by this actual criterion either
the neither political party that we have
when they have their own regimes would
actually be you know governing for the
benefit of the common good and that's a
really important thing to consider
another thing is even if it is
legitimate to overthrow the government
in a modern liberal democracy where you
know logistics transportation all the
you know the economy they're all closely
interconnected would you know the sort
of chaos that results from actually
overthrowing a government violently
because we're talking about violent you
know revolution in this case would that
really justify the benefits that are
going to come about that that's a vexed
question not one that you can answer in
the abstract
you have to look at a case by case by
case
so another question from Melanie Grace's
it begin what makes my government
legitimate and again I would say that it
has to in order to justify its its own
existence it can't just say well we're
here and we're in charge government
actually has to be for the benefit of
those who are being governed by it now
this could encompass a lot of different
things and quite often there will be a
lot of disagreement between the people
who are doing the governing and the
people who are being governed just how
how much benefit is actually being
conferred and oftentimes benefits are
hard to see you know the existence of
social order in the first place a lot to
be viewed as as indeed a benefit not as
just sort of something that you take for
granted but those are the those are you
know the sort of considerations that you
want to consider that you want to take
into consideration when you're thinking
about about the legitimacy of government
i would say that in our time we've
become accustomed to seeing legitimacy
as dependent to a certain extent upon
the ability for us to participate in in
governance right that's really a loser
II we don't in in modern liberal
democracies that we currently live in
except at the local level we really
don't have much opportunity to to cast
any sort of important vote you know I
for example live in a state where it
doesn't matter really who I vote for
States going to go blue or Democrat and
so you know I could vote Democrat if I
want but my vote doesn't count akin vote
Republican if I want I can throw it to a
third party if I want that doesn't
provide legitimacy so so we have to look
in other areas for for what counts as as
legitimacy
another question by Melanie Grace's it
begin and this is a really important one
that starts to get to the heart of
things who decides what's best for
society the citizens or the government
my answer both and neither because it's
it's posing this as if somehow the
citizens and the government are like two
different classes that you know one of
them might have the answer and the other
one doesn't really figuring out what's
best for society is always it's
something that's always in process we
have some guideposts we have some some
fixed points but there's other things
that are going to come up that we're not
quite sure about how to deal with you
know you know great example of that in
our own time is we're still kind of
trying to figure out what to do with
this thing that we call the internet and
who should own things and what is really
to the benefit of society and what is to
its detriment and and who's harmed and
who's helped those are things that
require to some degree the government to
be involved in but it's also the
citizens and i would say that II you
know yet more important than individual
citizens would be what we call voluntary
associations are what to Tocqueville
called intermediate institutions you
know and these would include things like
think tanks or or clubs or associations
of professionals you know all these
sorts of places where where ideas get
hashed out those are where a lot of the
discourse is about what's best for
society get get debated so you know
there's a tendency for the citizens
always to think my interest is the
interest of society there's a tendency
for those in charge in the government to
identify whatever will keep them in
power or make it easier for them as
what's good for society and we want to
have other other voices and perspectives
represented as well
gerald sword asks what is the first out
of batch of questions where do you stand
with regards to epistemology what is
your conception of truth so I'm going to
roll those two into one I don't think he
necessarily knows that that for me those
are very closely connected but turns out
they are for me epistemology I look at
it in a more classic sense you know
before there was epistemology there were
inquiries into knowledge and those were
always connected with truth and you know
the modes of knowledge and the types of
truth that we're dealing with and I
would say that when it comes down to it
my conception is you know less like
Thomas Aquinas a--'s where truth is
something that exists in the intellect
and you know if it exists outside of the
intellect it's because it exists in
God's intellect I don't see truth as
merely a matter of you know intellectual
add equation 2 to the things I see truth
in a sense that you you see in other
authors including you know particularly
seen an somewhere truth is something of
action and a being as well so I don't
actually do epistemology i do what i
would call metaphysics of knowledge and
think in terms of how those things
actually intersect with with action with
volition with choice which makes me very
eccentric and most epistemologists
probably wouldn't wouldn't be interested
in I sort of views on things but I think
it's legitimate to speak of truth in
terms of the will in terms of action in
terms of being in terms of relations not
just in terms of words things and and
thoughts
so here's a follow-up that Gerald sort
has in light of the neo pragmatic
approach to truth champion by the likes
of Rory and Davidson is the approach to
philosophy that it is about the truth
misguided should philosophy serve a
function more like keeping us honest so
two things that are going to sound kind
of flip right off the bat one is who
cares what Rory and Davidson think I
mean what whoever made them into the
Oracles about where we ought to be going
maybe they're actually misguided maybe
the fact that that some people have
bought into their their notions is just
a sign of the bankruptcy of those
people's understanding of things as well
as that of Rory and Davidson and whoever
else you like maybe it's a sign that
they were so out of touch with the
classic tradition that they couldn't get
out of it what they what they need it
and what it would it makes available
here's the second flip remark should
philosophy serve a function more like
keeping us honest i usually don't find
that people who are neo pragmatists are
all that honest and i find that their
conception of honesty tends to be very
shallow very adventitious and this is
just my own personal personal
observations you know you don't walk
down a dark alley with a
deconstructionist in part because they
don't really believe in much of anything
and they're they're willing to make
things you know shape and shift and
become what they like and from you know
a historical perspective you you see
that this is not really all that new
this sort of attitude towards things it
has different names at different times
but but it comes up over and over again
so you know if they want to you know lay
claim to something like keeping us
honest they need something to actually
ground that and it doesn't have to be
some sort of you know ironclad explains
everything theory but it better be
something more than just having a
conversation or what works or something
along those lines
so here's a question from somebody who's
name is just a mess water great books
that teach you how to philosophize and
how to write philosophy you're probably
not going to like my answer because I'm
not going to say a textbook and I'm not
going to say a history of philosophy and
I'm not going to say some sort of
secondary source instead what I'm going
to say is the great books if you want to
learn how to philosophize I think that
the best way to do that is to actually
read philosophy from the sources
themselves ideally if you can in the
original language and then after you've
actually you know for instance if you've
read some play-doh then you can read
some other people about Plato like you
know friedrich cobblestone he's not
going to steer you wrong or you can read
some play-doh scholars like you know say
Stan Lee Rosen gregory las dos but until
you've actually read the primary texts I
don't think it's really that great to
read digestion of them you want to
actually grapple with the stuff yourself
and it's going to take you some time and
it's it's a hard work and you got to
keep going back to it over and over and
over again but if you want to philosophy
as well I think that's what you need to
do now that's not to say that you can't
read people you know who are talking
about these great thinkers who are
oftentimes themselves great thinkers you
know in our own time Alistair McIntyre
would be a great example of that you
know Reed McIntyre you're going to learn
something about Plato and about Hagel
and about Nietzsche and about Sartre and
about all these other people but you're
also going to learn McIntyre's own take
which is very interesting in its own
right because he's a first-rate
philosopher so I would say you know you
want to learn how to write philosophy
you want to learn how to do philosophy
you gotta study the people who are
really good at it it helps to study with
somebody I think so that's the advice
I'd give
this is from zero she flies and he has
taken a whole set of questions that he
asked and condensed them down to
something very succinct and he's
probably going to get a little bit mad
at me because I'm going to suggest that
it's too succinct now so in your view
what makes for good philosophy as
opposed to stating mere opinion and I'd
say well I mean mere opinion is like way
over here and good philosophies over
here and there's a whole bunch of stuff
in between so I guess it is very
difficult to say you know there's no
single criteria for what what makes for
for good philosophy i would say that at
the very least you have to be providing
some sort of coherent not necessarily
systematic in the sense that everything
you know has it has its exact place and
always holds its place but some sort of
coherent developed account that actually
probes into things and doesn't remain
you know within the realm of just
everyday opinion you know what everybody
else says about it doesn't grab for the
first immediate straw and just stick you
know with that but moves on and tries to
examine things and then tries to
actually provide some sort of here's the
why here's the explanation for things
anybody can come up with an opinion and
say here's what I think and it's great
because i think it and that's what we
call mere opinion i tend to think that
we have to look to models when we're
thinking about good philosophy and
unfortunately a lot of people have
crappy models of what counts as good
philosophy and don't encounter a lot of
the good classical models of good
philosophy and end up just doing you
know doing stuff that's not particularly
good or interesting as a result i always
ask myself
should I read this or should I reread
Plato and because I know played it was
good philosophy and I don't know whether
this over here necessarily is
so Todoroki asks there's a famous quote
from Heidegger on the Zen scholar DT
suzuki that says if I understand this
man correctly this is what I've been
trying to say in all my writings if this
is the case what do you think Heidegger
is trying to say that Suzuki managed to
express I don't know and frankly I tend
not to pay much attention to those sort
of sayings I don't think that there's
one central insight to heidegger any
more than there's one central insight to
play doh there's one central insight to
Aristotle I think that heidegger himself
was wrong about that sort of thing in
his discussions about the history of
metaphysics that he was in a certain way
he's of his reductionist and he's being
that way towards himself and he's doing
himself a disservice because his
philosophy is you know great in part
because it's got a lot in its got it
some great stuff here and some great
stuff here and some great stuff here and
they don't always nap on to each other
and reduce to one central thing I have
no idea what particular insight that
heidegger thought he was in co Italy you
know gesturing at that he found in in
Suzuki I don't really see all those
those big similarities that a lot of
people want to point out between
Heidegger and and Buddhism despite the
fact that heidegger talks but nothing he
does not mean nothing in the way that
Buddhist mean the void or emptiness or
or nothingness and despite you know the
need to pay attention to things and to
to take in appearances as they are and
to not you know chain them to values or
things like that I don't really actually
see that as that close to Zen maybe I'm
in the minority on that though
so I am ending with a very tough
question by mark smith and he's
referencing my blog heavy metal
philosopher where I I'm trying to bring
together two things that are very
important in my life and not doing a
really successful job with it they
haven't written much on it lately
excitement I've been so busy here's this
question what do you think are some good
songs that present important
philosophical concepts how do they
convey these ideas effectively so it's
one thing to like rattle off a number of
songs and say well this one exemplifies
this or exemplifies this the how is the
really interesting question and i would
say some songs do so with philosophical
concepts and they could be
epistemological things or metaphysical
things more often metaphysical or moral
or aesthetic things and they're doing so
by by referencing them directly or in a
sort of mimetic way like for example
raschi's song free will where it's
something very similar to what you'd see
in sarn't you know if you choose not to
decide you still have made a choice that
sort of notion or they could be
exemplifying it through a kind of kind
of developing the character like think
about hawk wins master of the universe
they might be representing a certain
point of view on on the world or reality
or the way things are and I think a lot
of songs do that sort of thing and the
band itself might have a whole again
I'll use the word ethos going along with
that like think about you know the the
attitudes towards modernity that Black
Sabbath exemplified and technology and
how things are going sour you know or
you know Motorhead's sort of we're just
going to you know live as hard as we
possibly can and a go
of hedonism I'm already running out of
time there's a lot more to say about
this but I'm going to cut it short here